[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
8 august 1963 drei Uhr morgens der
Special Abzug der Westcoast mainline ist
ein rollendes Postamt
in den hinteren Waggons des Zuges sitzen
72 Postbeamte und sortieren die Briefe
die von Glasgow nach London gehen
18:50 Uhr hat er die schottische
Metropole verlassen in einer Stunde soll
er die britische Hauptstadt erreichen
der Zug wird von einer Diesel
elektrischen Lokomotive des Typs d326
gezogen im Führerhaus freuen sich der
58-Jährige Jack Mills und der 26-Jährige
David auf das Ende der langen Nachtfahrt
bei netburn ungefähr 70 km vor ihrem
Zielbahnhof Houston London stoßen sie
auf ein rotes Signale Licht
Milz stoppt den Zug noch nie ist er zu
dieser Zeit an dieser Stelle auf ein
Haltesignal gestoßen und er war schon
viele Nächte auf dieser Strecke
unterwegs er schickt seinen jüngeren
Mitarbeiter los
soll zum Signal laufen und mit dem dort
installierten Telefon die Leitstelle
anrufen und um Informationen bitten der
junge Mann springt aus dem Zug und
verschwindet in der Dunkelheit
Mils wartet
endlich hört er Schritte und Stiefel die
die Leiter der Lokomotive im vorklettern
doch das ist nicht Whitby der da in den
Führerstand klettert sofort versucht
Milch den Fremden zurückzudrängen da
wird auch die Tür an der anderen Seite
aufgerissen jemand stürmt in die
Lokomotive dann trifft etwas Hartes mit
großer Wucht seinen Hinterkopf und alles
wird schwarz
the great train robbery der legendäre
Post zu graub in England im Jahr 1963
das ist unsere heutige Geschichte hallo
und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland mein Name ist Toni Heyer und
ich bin Mirco Kasimir ja und heute geht
es wirklich um eines der berühmtesten
Verbrechen des 20 Jahrhunderts ein
Verbrechen das weltweit vor allem
natürlichen Großbritannien zu einem
festen Bestandteil der populär Kultur
geworden ist und das bis heute von
vielen eher gefeiert als verurteilt wird
ein Husarenstück eine Robin Hood Story
ein Schlag gegen das etablishment und
natürlich allen genialer Plan Ocean's
Eleven auf Schienen sozusagen ob das
alles gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht
werden wir noch sehen was wir schon
sagen können ist dass die ganze Sache
den meisten Beteiligten kein Glück
bringt einer begeht Selbstmord an
anderer wird ermordet fast alle landen
im Gefängnis und einer sogar auf einer
Platte der Toten Hosen Mirko lass uns
zuerst über den Zug sprechen also dieses
rollende post office ich habe natürlich
schon von diesem Zug Rap gehört aber das
da hinten im Zug 72 Leute in postuniform
saßen und Briefe sortiert haben das
wusste ich nicht also ich finde das
irgendwie eine ganz seltsame Vorstellung
ich meine klar liegt auf der Hand ist
eine ziemlich clevere Idee um die ganze
Postzustellung schneller zu machen aber
irgendwie auch ein bisschen lustig ja
train Office ist das ziemlich genaue
Gegenteil von Homeoffice würde ich sagen
ich versuche mir das gerade wie ein
richtiges Büro vorzustellen so mit
Schreibtischen auf denen irgendwelche
traurigen bräunlichen Grünpflanzen
stehen die noch nie das Tageslicht
gesehen haben okay Mirko aber bevor wir
abschweifen zurück zur Geschichte zumal
die Postbeamten in unserer Geschichte
überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielen also
sie sitzen in den hinteren Waggons des
Zug ist und eigentlich geht es nur um
den dritten Waggon in dem werden nämlich
die Wertsendungen Transport
er transportiert das Geld von
Bankfilialen in Glasgow zu ihrem
Hauptsitz in London normalerweise um die
zwei bis 300.000 Pfund pro Nacht doch in
dieser Nacht ist es wegen der
vergangenen Bank Feiertage mehr viel
mehr über zwei Millionen Pfund in
unsortierten unmarkierten scheinen und
auf die haben es die Posträuber
abgesehen aber um an den Wagen
heranzukommen müssen Sie den Zug stoppen
und manipulieren das Lichtsignal in der
Nähe von netburn okay also Signal
manipulieren klingt jetzt erstmal
irgendwie sehr dramatisch und aufwendig
ich kann euch sagen es war relativ
einfach denn sie haben bloß das grüne
Licht mit einem Handschuh verdeckt und
schließen eine Batterie an das rote
Licht an um es eben zum Leuchten zu
bringen einfach aber effektiv das sind
eigentlich immer die besten Pläne
definitiv es funktioniert ja auch der
Zug hält Bee steigt aus und stellt am
Signal fest dass die Kabel des Telefons
durchtrennt sind er kann also weder
Nachfragen noch Alarm schlagen auf dem
Rückweg zur Lokomotive fallen plötzlich
Männer über ihn her überwältigen ihn und
drohen ihn zu töten wenn er nur einen
Mucks von sich gibt dann stürmen sie das
Führerhaus der Lokomotive und schlagen
den Lokführer Jack Mills mit einer
Eisenstange bewusstlos während sich
andere Mitglieder der Bande daran machen
den hinteren Teil des Zuges abzukoppeln
die Bande will mit den beiden vorderen
Waggons noch etwa eine halbe Meile
weiterfahren zur bridico Bridge die
heute mandmor Bridge heißt dort wartet
der Rest der Bande mit zwei Land Rover
und einem armylastwagen auf den die
Beute verladen werden soll für diese
kurze Fahrt hat einer der Räuber ein
gewisser runny Biggs einen pensionierten
Lokführer aufgetrieben der das für die
Bande übernehmen soll den Namen habt ihr
sicher schon mal gehört und wir werden
natürlich später auch noch ausführlich
über ihn reden also über Ronny Bix und
der kennt die relativ neue Lokomotive
nicht und hat keine Ahnung wie er sie in
Bewegung setzen soll
finde jemanden der den Zug eine halbe
Meile weit fahren kann und das ist ein
absoluter Fell trotzdem wird Ronnie big
mit Abstand des berühmteste Mitglied der
Bande aber das liegt noch ein ganzes
Stück in der Zukunft den Räubern bleibt
nichts anderes übrig als den
eigentlichen Lokführer halbwegs wieder
zu Bewusstsein zu bringen und zu zwingen
den Zug zur geplanten Stelle weiter zu
fahren und so Rollen die Lok und die
vorderen beiden Waggons davon in die
Nacht während 69 der Postbeamten
ahnungslos weiter vor sich hinsortieren
Papierkorb Basketball spielen oder
heimlich ein Schluck Schnaps aus dem
Flachmann trinken ja Toni ich liebe
deine blühende Fantasie aber das hast du
dir ausgedacht oder
naja also so stelle ich es mir halt vor
aber das ist auch völlig egal also als
der vordere Zugteil an der bradic opeage
ankommt stürmt der Rest der Bande der
dort gewartet hat den Wagen mit den
Wertsendungen die drei Postbeamten darin
werden brutal niedergeschlagen und
gezwungen sich mit dem Bauch auf dem
Boden zu legen und vielleicht sollten
wir an dieser Stelle mal mit einem der
Mythen rund um diesen Raub aufräumen
Mirko ah das denke ich auch ein Großteil
seiner Popularität verdankt diese
Geschichte nämlich der Tatsache dass
niemand getötet wurde und das ist
natürlich auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache
aber es war trotzdem ein sehr sehr
rücksichtsloses Gewaltverbrechen man
vergisst oft das nicht nur physische
Gewalt Menschen schreckliches antut
sondern auch der purer Horror eines
solchen Überfalls es gibt Protokolle von
der ersten Vernehmung der Postbeamten
die im Wagen mit dem Geld mitfuhren und
aus denen sprechen Schock und Terror
diese Nacht wird sie nie wieder
loslassen
vor allem die beiden Lokführer leiden
ihr Leben lang an den psychischen Folgen
des Überfalls Jack Milz stirbt 7 Jahre
später an Leukämie David 8 Jahre später
an einem herzinfalt da ist er gerade
einmal 34 Jahre alt
[Musik]
nachdem die Postbeamten überwältigt sind
bilden die insgesamt 15 Räuber eine
Menschenkette und verladen 120 mit
geldgefüllte Säcke aus dem Zug in Ihren
LKW 30 Minuten nach Beginn des Überfalls
gibt der Anführer ein Zeichen die
vorgesehene Zeit ist abgelaufen die
Männer lassen acht Geldsäcke unberührt
stehen und fliehen mit 2,6 Millionen
britischen Pfund dem heutigen Gegenwert
von etwa 60 Millionen Euro das ist eine
Hausnummer fette Beute würde ich sagen
aber wer sind diese Männer man könnte
sagen dass ich hier zwei Banden
zusammengeschlossen haben als Master
meint der ganzen Operation geht Bruce
Reynolds der den Plan zusammen mit
Gordon Goody basta Edwards und Brian
field ausarbeitete dieses Kernteam hat
bereits einige erfolgreiche Überfälle
durchgeführt aber Ihnen fehlt die
Erfahrung mit Zug Überfällen weshalb sie
die Hilfe einer anderen Londoner Gang
suchen die sich das nennt die du da
dieser Bande sind Tommy whisby Bob world
Jim Hassi und Roger cordry sie kennen
sich damit aus und sind nur allzu gern
bereit in diese Sache mit einzusteigen
der Rest kommt im Laufe der
Vorbereitungen dazu auch Ronnie Biggs
aber wir sind ja schon ganzes Stück
weiter in unserer Geschichte ganz genau
der Überfall gelingt also obwohl der
angehörte ex-lokführer ein Totalausfall
ist und die Bande flieht mit der Beute
ohne Spuren am Tatort zu hinterlassen
auch die Flucht ist sehr genau und seit
Monaten geplant und vorbereitet aber
dieser Fluchtplan ist wahrscheinlich der
größte Fehler von Mastermind Reynolds
und den anderen über Strom Männer haben
sie zwei Monate zuvor einen
heruntergekommenen Bauernhof ca 28
Meilen vom Tatort entfernt gekauft dort
wollen sie unterkommen und sich
versteckt halten bis sich die erste
große Aufregung um den Überfall gelegt
hat vier Tage wollen sie sich dort
versteckt halten und anfangs scheint
doch alles gut zu gehen die Räuber
Teilen in aller Ruhe die Beute unter
sich auf und vertreiben sich dann die
Zeit indem sie Monopoly spielen mit
echtem Geld
doch es gibt zwei Probleme zum einen
sucht die Polizei intensiv nach einem
amelaster denn einer der Postbeamten
oder Zugführer konnte während der Tat
einen Blick auf das Fahrzeug erhaschen
als die Räuber in ihrem Versteck von
dieser Suche hören wissen sie dass ihr
eigentlicher Plan nicht funktionieren
wird sie wollten den Laster nutzen um
nach vier Tagen mitsamt der Beute
endgültig zu verschwinden aber das
Fahrzeug das können sie ja jetzt nicht
mehr benutzen immerhin gelingt es ihnen
aus London Ersatz zu besorgen doch es
gibt noch ein größeres Problem bevor die
Bande den Tatort verließ sagte einer der
Räuber zu den Postbeamten sie sollten
sich 30 Minuten lang nicht bewegen okay
das kann einfach so dahin gesagt gewesen
sein um einen möglichst großen Vorsprung
zu bekommen oder eben so überlegt sich
ein ziemlich schlauer Ermittler sie
brauchen eine halbe Stunde um sich eben
zu verstecken
Polizei und Scotland Yard setzen alles
auf diese Karte naja also nicht alles
natürlich werden die Häfen überwacht
aber die große Hoffnung ist dass die
Verbrecher dumm genug waren in der Nähe
zu bleiben und das waren sie wie wir
wissen in 30 Minuten kommt man nicht
allzu weit und die Polizei grenzt die
Suche auf einen 30 Meilen Radius um den
Tatort ein dort soll jedes mögliche
Versteck überprüft werden darunter jeder
Bauernhof als das in den Nachrichten im
Radio verbreitet wurde da dürfte die
Stimmung im Versteck ziemlich mies
geworden sein kann mir auch gut
vorstellen dass sie beim Monopoly
spielen ab da nur noch auf das Feld mit
dem Gefängnis gestartet haben
überstürzt bricht die Bande zwei Tage
eher als geplant von der Farm auf sie
haben keine Zeit mehr das Versteck
gründlich zu säubern aber das macht ihn
wenig Sorgen Brian field einer aus dem
harten Kern der Truppe soll die
Reinigung übernehmen und die Farm
anschließend niederbrennen ja das macht
der aber nicht viel belügt seine Kumpane
anfangs behauptet es hätte alles
geklappt doch nach ein paar Tagen muss
er zugeben dass er gelogen hat einige
aus der Bande wollen ihn auf der Stelle
töten die anderen können ihn jedoch
davor bewahren zu diesem Zeitpunkt haben
Polizei uns Gott und ja die verlassene
Farm bereits gefunden tatsächlich waren
sie nur ein paar Stunden nach der
überstürzten Flucht der Räuber vor Ort
es war den flüchtigen trotz der Eile
gelungen eine ganze Menge Spuren zu
beseitigen vor allem aber Fingerabdrücke
aber es sind noch genug übrig unter
anderem am Monopoly Spiel werden sie
einfach so weit wie möglich mit ihrer
Beute gefahren oder hätten sie das Geld
irgendwo vergraben und wären nach ein
paar Monaten zurückgekommen um es zu
holen wer weiß vielleicht wüssten wir
bis heute nicht wer den Zug wirklich
ausgeraubt hat naja Toni keine Ahnung
bei so vielen Beteiligten da ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit schon sehr groß dass
irgendjemand kapitalen bocken ist baut
der erst sich selbst und an alle anderen
ans Messer liefert betrunken damit
angeben oder keine Ahnung weiß der Geier
irgendwas ja da ist auch absolut recht
je mehr Leute involviert sind desto
größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
entweder dass man sich untereinander ums
Geld streitet oder dass jemand die
anderen ausliefert ja und so ist es dann
auch kein Wunder dass die meisten
Mitglieder der Bande binnen weniger
Monate
ins Gefängnis wandern es kommt also wie
wir anfangs schon gesagt haben der große
Post zu grau bringt große Beute und viel
mediale Aufmerksamkeit aber er bringt
den Räubern kein Glück mit den
Verhaftungen und Prozessen war die
Geschichte noch lange nicht zu Ende nein
denn es folgen noch jede Menge Drama
Flucht Liebe Punkmusik und hollywoodroom
Stoff genug für einen zweiten Teil
dieser spannenden Episode absolut Mirko
da haben wir ihn wieder den berühmten
Tatort Deutschland Tierfänger ich hoffe
dass er auch morgen wieder einschaltet
bei Teil 2 und bis dahin macht es gut
und bis morgen eure Toni und euer Mirko
ciao ciao